bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 l'accueil sur tv fil 78
du lundi au vendredi à 18h en direct
nous faisons le tour de l'actualité
locale les voici les principaux titres
de ce 26 mars des logements sociaux
économiques et écologiques c'est à saint
cyr l'école la réalisation quasiment
achevé représente un investissement de
plusieurs millions d'euros
jusqu'au 3 v l'hôtel de ville de
guyancourt accueille le salon réflexe
est dédié à la photographie et à la
création numérique et à guyancourt
justement le maire depuis 2002 françois
de ligne a été reconduit pour un nouveau
mandat et nous parlerons des dossiers
qui l'attendent et de la bascule
possible de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à droite à
saint cyr l'école un projet écologique
est sur le point d'être achevés 34
logements sociaux en bois sont
actuellement en construction
coût de l'opération pour le bailleur
plus de 6 millions d'euros
sabrina c'est qu'il est un chantier en
apparence comme les autres ou presque
car dans ces constructions d'achèvement
cours à saint cyr l'école nous pensé
avant tout développement durable ici la
structure des immeubles est réalisée en
bois le bois déjà un coefficient
d'isolation qui est plus importante que
le béton
dès qu'on vous toucher du bois et c'est
bon il fait pas froid vous touchez du
béton c'est froid ce sont des bâtiments
qui sont très bien isolée pour
travailler dans le sens de l'économie
d'énergie est aussi utilisé d'énergies
qui est renouvelable le bois ont fait
pousser des arbres on les coupe on
construit avec orphée poussins d'autres
armes
le béton on en tire toujours dans les
énergies fossiles
il ya une brune elle tient sa
connaissance du bois d'un long séjour en
scandinavie pour lui la construction de
ce type d'habitation collective et
appelé à se développer dans l'hexagone
selon lui le bois permet une économie
d'énergie d'environ 20% par rapport au
béton le bailleur lui a en tout cas été
sensible à ce procédé on entrer dans une
démarche de développement durable dans
les années 2000 et donc on cherche avant
tout à faire des économies d'énergie des
économies de ressources et limiter les
consommations les les productions de gaz
à effet de serre donc le bois est un
matériau qui n'y répond à toutes ces
problématiques
c'est le seul matériau de construction
qui est durable et qui naturel autre
démarche en faveur de l'écologie
l'installation de panneaux solaires qui
permettra aux familles de réaliser des
économies
60 % de l'eau chaude sera autofinancé
grâce au solaire thermique
les occupants ne devront financer que
les 40% restant un gain non négligeable
pour les futurs locataires qui devraient
emménager d'ici trois mois à guyancourt
la société en vol s'ils me proposent
depuis fin 2013 un simulateur de vol une
machine destinée aussi bien aux pilotes
professionnels confirmés qu'aux
passionnés ou novices sensation assuré
olivier maniscalco jonathan vilma
si maxime se fait briefé par arnaud sur
les techniques de décollage c'est que
dans quelques minutes
il montera à bord d'un simulateur de vol
installé dans la zone du moulin à vent à
guyancourt la société envol sim propose
depuis fin 2013 de retrouver les
sensations d'un avion de tourisme cessna
en plus de ces trois écrans triptyque
qui donnent l'illusion d'être à 120
degrés dans un paysage photoréaliste le
simulateur reproduit les mouvements que
l'on ressent dans un cockpit et on peut
même le configurer pour des conditions
de vol difficile tout ce qui est
sensation de roulement sur une piste
décollage virage accélération
décélération atterrissage on les ressent
comme si on était à bord d'un wagon
on peut aussi jouer sur les paramètres
météo et donc que simuler des brumes
travers de l'appui la tempête et donc
voilà tous ces phénomènes là on les
ressent comme si on était véritablement
à bord d'un avion le simulateur
s'adresse donc initialement aux pilotes
pour parfaire leur formation mais pas
uniquement il permet aussi aux amateurs
qui simule leur vol sur pc de passer à
la vitesse supérieure et aux débutants
comme maxime de ressentir les premières
sensations de pilotage
ça s'est bien passé comme la dernière
fin
non bien aidé côté tarif il vous faudra
débourser 75 euros de l'heure pour
monter à bord du simulateur
néanmoins des journées découvertes sont
mis en place certains samedis ou 10
euros vous offriront 15 minutes de vol
nous avons comme chaque soir de cette
semaine une page politique une page
municipal et voisins le bretonneux il
faudra un second tour pour départager
les candidats les quatre listes ont
obtenu le minimum nécessaire de 10% des
suffrages pour se maintenir mais les
accords se sont conclues à droite contre
le maire alexis piette qui faisait
l'union entre l'ump élus des îles points
avec anthony rech
avec plus de 12 % des voix au premier
tour
il était en capacité de se maintenir
mais conformément à ses engagements
jean-louis tison se retire et appelle à
voter pour l'ancienne première adjointe
d'alexis millette
nous avons été proches d'une union avant
le premier tour et je pense que c'est le
moment aujourd'hui de dire alexandra
rose éthique je félicite pour son bon
résultat supérieur aux bien sûr le
premier tour eh bien je concrétise
l'accord que nous avions entre nous que
le meilleur gagne c'est elle qui a
réussi le premier tour et l'ensemble de
mes voix iront sur elle pour le deuxième
tour face au fort taux d'abstention de
42 % lors du premier tour la principale
rivale annoncée du maire sortant
alexandra rosetti crédité de 28,40 6%
des suffrages entend profiter des voix
de jean-louis tison et surtout
rassembler le maximum d'antibes y est
pour ce second tour
je pense que il faut que les gens se
rassemblent et j'espère qu'ils vont
entendre que tout ne peut pas se faire
autour des partis politiques que quand
on veut être maire d'une ville
il faut rassembler tout le monde et ne
pas se dire est méprisé une certaine
catégorie de la population parce
qu'elles ne votent pas comme on aimerait
qu'elle vote moi je souhaite rassembler
les gens parce que je trouve que c'est
comme ça qu'on pourra travailler
ensemble et continuer à construire notre
ville face à cette union le maire
sortant alexis bj est arrivé en tête au
premier tour avec 39,60 2% des suffrages
entend bien convaincre les
abstentionnistes pour remporter cette
élection
on va expliquer exactement les points
essentiels de notre programme
et puis surtout appelé à la mobilisation
parce qu'on voit que le climat national
ne pousse pas vraiment à la mobilisation
ce qui est dommage parce que les enjeux
sont des enjeux locaux et donc on
poussera vraiment à la mobilisation à la
participation maximum au milieu de cette
guerre à droite la seule liste de gauche
menée par jean h n'a recueilli que 19,69
% soit 9 points de moins qu'en 2008
un score jugé décevant par le candidat
divers gauche qui le met dans une
situation délicate pour le second tour
ça pas du tout été facile parce
qu'aucune de nos défis jour aucune des
solutions que l'on retrait était bonne
dans les deux cas c'est mauvais mais il
faut bien faire un choix et on a fait le
choix de ne pas abandonner le terrain
nous espérons faire prendre conscience à
un voisin que d'un côté le maire un
bilan désastreux queue de lotte
alexandra rosetti c'est un changement
pour rien verdict ce dimanche 30 mars à
partir de 20 heures
je reçois à présent pour cette édition
du 26 mars françois de ligne et bonsoir
mention maire de guyancourt socialiste
vous avez été réélu dimanche soir avec
le 67,74 % des suffrages c'est malgré
tout un peu moins bien qu'en 2008 où
vous aviez fait 73 % même si cela reste
sur ce scrutin le meilleur résultat sur
saint quentin en yvelines
comment vous expliquez avoir réussi à
résister à cette vague de la droite
aussi bien en france qu'en ile de france
dans le département même alors c'est
vrai que le contexte n'est pas du tout
celui de d'il ya six ans et donc on
considère que c'est un très très bon
score c'est près de 68% 15 bureaux de
vote
le grand chelem des bureaux montant
jusqu'à 77% et vous l'avez dit dans un
dans un contexte où il ya un recul de la
gauche je crois qu'il faut être lucide
de cela je pense que le score qu'on a
fait d'ailleurs sans doute le plus élevé
de saint quentin en yvelines mais si on
regarde les communes de gauche de
manière plus large
c'est également le cas dans l'est dans
les yvelines comment l'expliquer je
dirais que il ya un bilan et des
propositions qui ont été formulées par
mon équipe il ya une dynamique et je
pense que les habitants n'ont reconnu et
mes premiers mots ça sera pour remercier
les légumes courtois il nous renouvelle
la confiance
nous avons donc la possibilité et la
garantie de poursuivre un projet de
ville ce projet de ville les habitants
le connaissent bien et guyancourt
je pense que c'est cette proximité c'est
cette notion de solidarité priorité à
l'éducation de cadre de vie auquel nous
sommes très attentifs
ces raisons qui font qu'à mon avis les
aiguillons contre eux ne se sont pas
trompés on vous parlait de l'adhésion de
la population des guyancourt toit des
nuits en courtoise l'abstention un
électeur sur deux qui ne s'est pas
déplacé 49 % environ d'abstention soir
là sur la commune
l'abstention c'est toujours toujours
toujours trop élevés et quelles que
soient les circonstances on note en plus
etc général que dans les quartiers plus
populaires l'abstention est plus forte
ce qui veut dire que on a besoin de
faire un travail d' attention pour ne
pas que le lien entre des habitants et
leurs élus se distendent je crois que ça
c'est une question prioritaire
le parti socialiste dans le département
connaît une sévère déconvenue perte de
poids si père de bois d'arcy également
perte de l'agglo peut-être on va y venir
dans un instant vous avez le sentiment
là véritablement les électeurs envoie un
message qu'ils veulent une autre
politique du gouvernement et puis quel
regard portez-vous sur la politique
menée par le gouvernement vous pensez
qu'il faut des changements aussi
peut-être avant de parler de de l'aspect
national sur l'aspect départementale
on peut noter une situation particulière
c'est celle de saint quentin en yvelines
je note que l'ensemble des municipalités
de gauche sortante
je pense à la verrière à magny les
hameaux à guyancourt bien sûr et demain
j'en suis certain à trappes deuxième
tour on a des municipalités de gauche
qui ont fait des bons résultats et qui
vont pouvoir être reconduit c'est un
petit peu le paradoxe puisque vous
l'avez dit dans le département
le recul est manifeste et là évidemment
ça pose la question du vent nationale
contraire et du fait qu' il ya une
sanction c'est certain je reprenais
cette sanction
bien que vous portez sur la politique
monsieur alors je pense qu'ils aient une
attente formidable de la part de nos
concitoyens
après la crise économique qui se
poursuit d'ailleurs avec la question
prioritaire très très importante de
celles de l'emploi avec les
préoccupations quotidiennes de nos
concitoyens également en matière de
transport en matière de logement par
exemple ou en matière d'éducation
on peut comprendre que les attentes
soient très très forte là on a un
décalage entre les mesures qui tarde qui
sont peut-être longue à se mettre en
place et les attentes qui elles sont
très très fortes et depuis longtemps ça
vous faites partie de ceux au parti
socialiste qui demandait un changement
une inflexion très nette on en vient
l'agglomération on reviendra ensuite à à
guyancourt sur vos projets mais déjà
l'agglomération qui pourrait basculer à
droite il reste deux villes avec un
second tour à trappes voisins le
bretonneux également il suffit d'un
conseiller à droite pour trappe pour que
l'agglomération bascule et que la
situation ne change pas à
voisins-le-bretonneux qu'on reste sur le
même équilibre
vous pensez que c'est d'ores et déjà
perdu aujourd'hui une élection n'est
jamais fait d' avance il faut attendre
ce deuxième tour ce qui est certain
c'est que là on va être très très très
très serré dire que dans tous les cas on
aura entre les représentants de la
gauche à la communauté d'agglomération
et les représentants de la droite
ça sera dans un mouchoir de poche ce qui
veut dire que dès à présent il faut le
rappeler un se pose la question de à
quoi sert un conseiller communautaire
qu'est ce que la communauté
d'agglomération et quel est son rôle
les conseillers de guyancourt mme je les
dis dès le soir des résultats puisque
c'est la première fois qu'on veut en
même temps que pour l'élection
municipale
on vote pour les conseillers
communautaires les conseillers les huit
qui représenteront la majorité de
guyancourt auront une double double
responsabilité à la fois celle de
représenter les intérêts de guyancourt
en tant que commune de l'agglomération
et celle également de défendre
j'allais dire quel que soit le résultat
des autres communes de défendre la
réussite de saint quentin en yvelines
sur bien des plans
je voudrais rappeler que là ça montre le
rôle d'une agglo je leur ai rappelé qu'
environ 50% des services sont intégrés
maintenant en terme d'intercommunalité
donc ne dépende plus seulement de la
commune
ça veut dire qu'on aura à travailler à
la fois sur le projet communal ce conte
on a dit pendant exprimé pendant cette
élection et qu'en même temps on aura à
défendre une idée d'intercommunalité
qu'est-ce qu'on mutualisent qu'est ce
qu'on met en commun et là dans tous les
cas je serai de ceux qui défendront la
notion d'un projet solidaire c'est à
faire en sorte que la solidarité sous le
coeur d'un projet de d'intercommunalité
et également sur des sujets qui peuvent
être sensibles sur lesquels il peut ya
voir qui va je pense par exemple à la
nécessité de défendre la culture la
culture c'est pas quelque chose quelque
chose qu'on peut comme ça balayés demain
est évidemment puisque je parlais de par
exemple de solidarité
si on prend la notion de l'habitat
diversifier sur nos territoires
là il ya un travail qui sera défendre
parce que je ne voudrais pas qu'on
revienne en arrière avec par exemple des
clivages où certaines villes ne ferait
que de l'accession de propriété pendant
que d'autres porterait les besoins en
matière de besoins sociaux
ce sont deux projets qui s'en posent en
fait un celui de la gauche et de la
droite ne serait ce que sur la question
du développement de saint quentin en
yvelines on en avait déjà parlé sur ce
plateau que ce soit vers le yen de
saclay alors ce qui concerne la gauche
en ce qui concerne la droite c'est plus
le développement du bassin de vie avec
un agrandissement de l'agglomération aux
communes avoisinantes la droite en tout
cas qui accélère dans cette campagne
cette dernière ligne droite de
l'entre-deux tours ottomanes massereau
le candidat de l'ump de la droite à
trappes qui a reçu cet après midi le
soutien sur le terrain vous le voyez de
david douillet du nouveau maire de
poissy aussi le conseiller général et
karl olive c'était cet après midi à
trappes
vous vous attendiez à un second tour en
triangulaire justement à trappes attrape
compte tenu du nombre de listes je m'y
attendais mais je m'attends à ce que la
gauche gagne et je voudrais dire que
l'élan et les résultats qu'on a pu avoir
dès le premier tour à guyancourt on peut
désespérer attrape et c'est bien le but
dès la semaine dès la semaine prochaine
dès dimanche prochain
une petite prépare très très fort 4 1
une petite remarque il ya l'enjeu de
l'agglomération ce n'est pas le nouveau
maire de poissy
ni david douillet qui gérons
l'agglomération je voudrais rappeler à
nos concitoyens je leur ai rappelé aux
saint quentinois que nous avons un enjeu
qui est à la fois municipales et
intercommunales
il faut rester sur ces enjeux de
territoire et ne pas aller dans d'autres
considérations qui seraient trop
politicienne et on le voit dans le
l'amas de la manière dont la droite
départementale essaye de se donner comme
objectif de capter parce que c'est quand
même le mot qui est très très souvent
dans l'esprit de certains de capter un
territoire
vous avez déjà répondu en partie à cette
question mais si l'agglomération bascule
est ce que ça pourrait freiner les
projets que vous avez ne serait ce que
pour votre commune pour rien en cours
alors j'ai toujours été dans la
situation précédente et je vois pas
pourquoi je changerais demain j'étais
toujours été je voulais dit tout à
l'heure conscients du fait qu'ils
avaient les deux niveaux donc au niveau
de l'intercommunalité
évidemment dans le cas de figure que
vous citez je serai extrêmement attentif
à ce que une gouvernance intègre les
dimensions de chaque commune
les communes ont leurs impératifs les
communes ont leurs exigences allaient
dire en terme de deux territoires à
développer il faut que ça s'intégrer
dans une intercommunalité on l'a dit
tout à l'heure
et donc il faudrait être très très
attentif à ça je donne des exemples
pendant la ce dernier mandat et même
celui d'avant il y avait la notion de
conseil des maires un conseil des maires
c'est avec les sept
et je rappelle que demain dans tous les
cas de figure quel que soit le président
il y aura quatre maires de gauche et
trois de droite
le conseil des maires donc à voir aussi
toute son importance sinon ça serait
venir une partie des communes
on a toujours dit on l'a appliqué et si
demain c'est parce que je souhaite mais
si demain et de lévriers alternance je
veillerai à ce que cela soit appliqué de
même pour un certain nombre de sujets
qui l'a doivent faire consensus
je veux dire par exemple qu'un réseau de
transport en commun il fonce pas de
couleur politique quand il traverse la
limite d'une commune c'est un réseau qui
n'est pas un réseau communal mais qui
est un réseau comme une intercommunale
et on aura besoin de le travailler
ensemble pour conclure vos projets le
projet prioritaire peut être sur votre
commune vous être élus pour six ans
alors vous savez être réduits c'est à la
fois porter l'attention la vie
quotidienne sur beaucoup de sujets j'en
ai évoqué pendant pendant la campagne de
très nombreux le logement l'éducation je
pourrais multiplier les exemples
c'est aussi avoir une vision d'avenir ce
qui va être prioritaires pour réduit en
cours ces deux d'arriver à ce que
l'harmonie de la ville qui est basée sur
de grands équilibres puisse se
poursuivre dans un cadre qui est quand
même nouveau c'est celui d'une nouvelle
opération d'intérêt national et donc là
nous avons cet enjeu
formidable d'arriver à maintenir les
grands équilibres maintenir la couronne
verte on a déjà obtenu par exemple la
sanctuarisation des terres agricoles
permettre le développement équilibré
c'est à dire continuer à accueillir des
entreprises vous faire par exemple que
le parc plus ancien des entreprises qui
deviennent obsolètes puisse être
renouvelée et en même temps faire des
opérations à taille humaine de manière à
ce que notre équilibre autour de 30
mille habitants puissent se poursuivre
grossir pour grossir n'a pas d'intérêt
veiller aux équilibres de la commune
c'est ma priorité
merci françois de ligne et maire de
guyancourt réélu donc avec le 67 points
74 % à des voir merci à vous d'être
chaud mais sitôt ce week end les
élections municipales était dans toutes
les têtes mais cela n'a pas empêché les
habitants de trappes de plaisir aussi de
fêter leur carnaval des événements qui
ont remporté un franc succès éclair
cambier julien leroy et ont assisté de
la couleur et du rythme samedi trappe à
fêter la deuxième édition de son
carnaval de printemps la ville a déroulé
le tapis rouge pour la compagnie de
danse difé kako
l'occasion pour les habitants de voyager
vers des horizons lointains difé kako
c'est
ça signifie en créole guadeloupéen
quelque chose qui chauffe et on pratique
un mélange entre eux les danses des
antilles et les danses de l'afrique
l'objectif c'est d'impliquer des publics
locaux voilà en l'occurrence des publics
trappistes qui ce qu'on né à trappes
aujourd'hui est de leur transmettre une
chorégraphie sur laquelle ils vont
pouvoir défiler avec nous faut pour
préparer ces festivités la compagnie a
animé de nombreux ateliers au programme
court de danse et de musique mais aussi
fabrication de costumes
le résultat a séduit des habitants après
une animation pour trappe
ça fait très plaisir les questions sont
très jolis décidant ce bien c'est très
beau c'est rythmé
dimanche le quartier des gâtines de
plaisir fêtait également son carnaval
avec une météo pour le moins capricieuse
cela n'a toutefois pas empêché les
habitants d'être de la fête
c'est une journée importante au carnaval
fait partie de la tradition j'avais
envie que les enfants puissent voir un
défilé puisque à l'école le petit la
firme internet malheureusement primaires
ça se perd un petit peu c'est toujours
très sympathique de voir un défilé de
couleurs et puis plein choses
magnifiques
les enfants n'étaient pas les seuls à
s'être prêté au jeu des déguisements les
adultes aussi ont rivalisé d'imagination
pour être dans l'ambiance
ça vous rappelle les souvenirs d'enfance
de carnaval j'imagine mais j'ai pas eu
le chance d'en avoir quand j'étais petit
donc là j'en profite beaucoup plus
maintenant quand je suis grand je me
déguisais etc
à l'honneur jusqu'au 3 avril l'hôtel de
ville de guyancourt accueille le salon
un réflexe dédié à la photographie à la
création numérique un concours gratuit
et pour les amateurs et une occasion
d'exposer ses plus belles oeuvres
aurélia de bissy troisième année de
rendez vous pour les amateurs de
photographie et de création numérique le
salon réflexe organisé par la ville de
guyancourt expose ses oeuvres jusqu'au 3
avril
la mezzanine de l'hôtel de ville réflexe
en fait c'est la place de l'amateur dans
la création et la photographie donc
c'est un salon qui a été que vous l'avez
dit à trois ans en deux volonté de
pouvoir faire participer les amateurs de
lui en cours mais également hors du en
cours pour voir exposer d'avoir un temps
d'exposition pour montrer leurs
créations avant d'être exposé les
créations de sont sélectionnés par un
jury de professionnels au total 38
oeuvres ont été retenues pour participer
au concours
trois catégories sont représentées
photographies noir et blanc couleurs ou
encore création numérique à l'occasion
du vernissage le 27 mars
le jury décernera 4e pris un par
catégorie et le coup de coeur du jury
enfin un dernier dédié à la sélection du
public sera également remis ce jour là
les votes sont d'ores et déjà ouverts à
tous une dernière information pour
refermer ce journal selon airparif le
seuil de pollution atmosphérique aux
particules est susceptible d'être
atteint demain jeudi 27 mars il est donc
recommandé d'éviter vous le savez toutes
activités physiques et sportives
intenses
et bien sûr d'éviter d'utiliser son
véhicule pour se déplacer
l'aktu revient à demain 18h en direct
sur télé fils je recevrai alain ajaj le
maire front de gauche réélu à la
verrière votre soirée sur tv fils c'est
notamment avec kiosques le magazine de
la culture présentée par aurélia de 8,6
mais aussi la rediffusion des 20 heures
du débat de l'entre-deux tours à voisins
le bretonneux présenté par catherine
mulato excellente soirée